King Charles just visited Kenya for the
first time since becoming King and it
was kind of awkward Kenya is a former
British colony and they've been
celebrating their 60th anniversary of
independence from Britain this year but
the history is kind of horrible back in
the 1950s the British Administration
rounded up and tortured thousands of
Kenyans who were fighting against
colonial rule for years Kenyans have
demanded a formal apology and
reparations from the UK and for some
reason the UK refuses to give it to him
the king did acknowledge in this speech
that Britain had some wrongdoings in the
past but he didn't apologize it turns
out that he actually doesn't have the
power to apologize only the United
Kingdom government is allowed to do that
and they definitely should Kenya is
actually a very significant place for
the British it was during her visit in
1952 that Elizabeth learned that she was
going to be the next Queen of England
though King Charles's speech was a move
in the right direction it wasn't a full
apology and it's not nearly enough to
atone for the sins of British
colonialism if you want to better
understand global politics follow along
for more